I am very happy to inform you that today
we reach an agreement on the automatic
exchange of information in the field of
Taxation in relation to reportable
cross-border arrangements we are happy
to see an agreement on this point
because the measures foreseen in this
proposal will help Member States protect
their tax bases from erosion erosion and
consequently protect the revenues to the
national budgets today we also updated
the euro list of non cooperative
jurisdictions for tax purposes the
conceived agreed to add three countries
the Bahamas st. Kitts and Nevis and the
US Virgin Island we also agreed to add
another four countries Anguilla Antilla
and Barbuda in the British Virgin
Islands and Dominic Dominica together
with my colleagues we agreed on the euro
position for g20 finance ministers and
central bank governors meeting which
will take place in a week in Buenos
Aires in my role of a president of the
echo fin calcio I will have the honor to
represent the you together with
colleagues from the European Commission
and the European Central Bank I would
like to say a few words on the risk
reduction banking package the presidency
has worked very hard with the
delegations to find a compromise
satisfactory to all Member States but
some more time is needed today the
European Union has reiterated its
commitment to bring more transparency to
the world of aggressive tax planning we
are global frontrunners in this field
and European Union of course will use
its political influence to push for a
similar action in the international
level